yo it's the bootleg head podcast
uh we got a special guest uh legendary
hip-hop journalist
b dot my guy bdot from rap radar
what's up okay how you doing man you
look good man how you doing
i'm good it's crazy because i i
specifically remember
this time last year you and elliot
ran my dude i was playing video games in
my man cave
watching that drake interview and then
the griselda interview followed up
it was just it was like some of the best
it was like a historical month
because those were two of the best
interviews especially that drake
interviews like a historical interview
and you guys have a lot of those yeah
man that was hard to keep a secret you
know i had to
hold that in for like two weeks and we
decided to do it on christmas day
because you know it's christmas
yes our gift to y'all you know so it was
amazing man
thank you man i appreciate it it's hard
watching those interviews back because
then i'm like damn i should have asked
this question or i should have
framed it this way so i always cringe
when i watch
the interviews again but you know it
seems like everyone
enjoyed it so i feel like that always
happens
when you interview someone like that
you're always like [ __ ]
i forgot to ask this and then you like
yourself all the way
back home like [ __ ] but you know it
happens you know you catch him next time
around
what was something you you you had uh
felt that way about with the drake
interview like that you would wish you
would have asked him
um i think i would have asked him more
about nicki minaj in their relationship
yeah
i think there was something about cuddy
i wanted to ask him about
but um that was that was about it so
you know next time around right for sure
man um and you guys have been doing a
great job throughout the pandemic like
you know with the with the you know the
title check-ins and you have your uh
it's the art art
what is the art of wraps or artifacts
what is it
that's called artifacts to play on order
the word artifacts
right so it was just basically kind of
like a hip-hop show-and-tell i had this
idea
for a long time i pitched it to mtv me
and it canon actually were partners on
it
it was another it was another name
called junkies and i just switched the
name
and we had pitched it to mtv and viacom
and things were in motion
but you know how that happens you know
things got do weighed
and um i decided to just do it on my own
and
so far so good i'm enjoying it all right
so let's get to this list of yours man
first of all you got multiple lists
multiple lists i have lists on lists
i think i'm gonna put out another one
too my best albums today i was gonna say
yeah
i got mine i was gonna share with you so
um
well well first of all this will be
probably come out if you're gonna if
you're gonna release that today
yeah we can share it on the podcast so
it's gonna come out after
um let's let's start with the things we
we strongly agree upon and that's
freddie gibbs now
you and i have been a part of the
freddie gibbs wave for a very long time
the first time i interviewed fred was in
09
um you know he's he's always been one of
my favorite rappers in the world
and um you know obviously he had the
esgn
uh you know when he was doing his sports
column with you with rap
rap radar.com yeah yeah and uh you know
i think that it's you know finally
every everything's kind of coming around
for fred you know as far as just
peers respect and you know and mind you
i think in 2014
pinata was a classic last year bandana
was a classic
um he was my best rap of last year too i
agree
um and i always kind of get like yo man
that he's your boy so you're i'm like
nah man fred is that guy
so i think i think let's talk about
fred's year man because you know i think
freddie gibbs
you know even going back to last year um
you'd be hard-pressed to find a
two-album
run i mean there are those that exist
obviously but man that's a hell of a
two-album run
i agree no i think you have bandana like
you said last year and just this one
this year is just like alfredo is
incredible
i think fred is rapping at a really
really high level it's at the point
where
when he's rapping i'm on the edge of my
seat just anticipating what he's going
to say next
like he's at that level now you know and
so i'm just really happy that he's
finally getting the recognition he
deserves i mean
i think the grammy nominations
definitely put the spotlight on him
a little bit more and it's funny because
i remember talking to him throughout the
year that's all he kept talking about
randy nomination like for him the
nomination is probably
already a win so i'm really happy for
him and um i hope he does take it home
yeah it was important to him last year
too i think that that was a big a big
reason why they did
the album with the rca last year yeah
absolutely
and you know he got snubbed last year so
this year definitely
it definitely felt like okay finally i
mean yeah in general the grammy
nominations this year for best rap album
if i had to put money on it yeah
like my own money yeah i think
nas probably goes home with the trophy
yeah not because it's the better album
right i agree but it's just like how
many times has not been nominated and he
hasn't gotten a grammy i feel like
[ __ ] susan lucci of rap you know i'm
saying like he keeps getting nominated
for different awards and he just never
wins
so i think they'll give it to him this
time around but so you know
see they're going to be him or alfredo i
don't think anybody else has a chance
yeah surprises happen i never forget
when um
drake and justin bieber were up for best
new artist and esmeralda's spalding one
i was like who the [ __ ] is this
yeah i still don't know who that is
exactly so
surprisingly i think even the last year
they had a tie
if i'm not mistaken right or was it the
year before it was
time for the best rap performance yeah i
don't remember yeah that's
crazy yeah yeah i think i think um fred
deserves to win it
and i think i think the betting
favorite's got to be nas though just
because it's like when leo dicaprio had
all those oscar nominations and they
finally
gave him one you know what i'm saying is
um
and then another person who you had high
on your list
who i think also doesn't get a lot of
enough respect
he's not he's around 10 on mine but
your list you had russ really high and i
think russ doesn't get enough love he
doesn't get enough respect i also think
you know people just it's kind of
popular to just not like russ to dislike
the guy
it's hard being a white rapper these
days well he's also really cocky and
like he make
you know i always say like russ gives
out so much free game that artists
should like
really listen to you know what i'm
saying like
okay i'm sorry and as i say like that's
even even if you take his music and his
skill out of it like he's really
dropping like
serious gems that any artist should
listen to i agree i think russ is nice
if you're a rap fan
and you don't like gravitate to russia's
lyrics like i just can't really respect
your opinion
i think a lot of people don't even give
him a shot because if you're open
to his rhymes he's spitting his ass off
i think the chomp ep was a great example
of that
and just all for the freestyles that he
peppered throughout the year uh
specifically the the live from the villa
one
mm-hmm freestyle like that's freestyle
it's crazy
how can you listen to that and not you
know give him his props so
i think russ you know he does a lot of
the pop records as well so i think that
gets mitigate that gets overshadowed by
the rap stuff
right you know russ is incredible he
could really wrap his ass off and
hang with the best of them um who
was somebody who you um
you think was like knocking on your like
top 10 that didn't necessarily make it
this [ __ ] was hard like i was wrestling
with this list for at least
since like thanksgiving it's rough it is
hard
and plus i do it for 10 just to you know
yeah to focus on that
but um someone who i think could like if
you did like 11 like honorable mentions
um larry june okay okay
that larry june project it might make
the list
hey larry june is crazy he put a whole
album out with burner too he had a crazy
year
larry june that keep going project is
fire yes
james uh the price of tea in china james
had a crazy year
uh smoke dizza his album fire like
there's a lot of rappers that i
personally like but i can't necessarily
put them on the best
rapper list because i feel like they had
the skill but did they have the presence
or did they have you know the
performance on tracks i'm just i'm
trying to be objective and also
subjective at the same time
so now um somebody who i didn't include
in my top 10 list because technically
his album came out in january
or december of last year and someone who
i
consider um to have the best melodies in
all all of hip-hop
is roddy rich and i know a lot of people
have been you know and i i don't
disagree with anybody who thinks roddy
rich should be
on that list i just kind of i think
marathi rich is
one of the best song makers right period
i agree i think righty rich is a better
right rich direct you know i'm saying
i'm not saying he can i know for sure
but i've also believe he's like a
product of 2019 more so than 2020
and um his album lived a lot this year
man
it did but it came out last year you
know right right
right that's that's just how i base it
off and also i don't think
when i think of best rappers like i
don't
for me i don't put roddy rich in that
category he's not a person that comes to
mind
he can make a great song but when i
think like the best rappers is going to
make me go ooh
nah it's not necessarily rotty rich yeah
i'm going to give you a quick rundown of
my 10.
please i got freddie gibbs at one okay
i got conway at two so so far we're two
for two on our list
all right i'm with it benny at three
okay
we're three for three mozzie at four
so i we gotta start putting some respect
on mazzy's name man
i like mozambique put out two great
albums this year
i like mozzie and he's like to me the
one guy
obviously he's from sacramento but like
when it comes to like the west coast
[ __ ] like
i feel like he is the guy who everybody
respects who you'll meet
as a rapper too so i got mozzie high on
my list man i'm not mad at that
i got big sean at five i really enjoyed
uh detroit too i really enjoyed his
presence on a lot of other people's
records obviously
full things with gibbs see we did uh we
have
big sean both at five then do we yeah
okay yeah
i have books on five things are gonna
get real different than here
i got um i got royce to five nine at six
okay
and i don't think royce made your list i
didn't make i was thinking about royce
too but
what did it what prevented royce from
making the list is the fact that he put
out i liked allegory
but i also think if it wasn't for the
grammys that album would have been
forgotten about
and after allegory i don't think he
really did anything else throughout the
year he was kind of silent
yeah i mean he was on sean's album i
mean he also he also i mean look i also
go back to the eminem album
he gassed the m album he produced on the
m album yeah um
i'm gonna go killer mike at seven run
the jules four is is
is a an incredible album to me so i got
killer mic at seven
i'm at that i think oola allows one of
the best rap songs of the year
walking on the snow is the one for me
man the one with uh gangsta boo on the
hook
um another artist who's not on your list
i got busta rhymes at eight
really yeah man i really love yelling
too man
you like that album i really enjoyed it
bro i hated that album felt like
homework when i was
you hated the album i hated it really
it was one it was too long and busted
just to me it just felt like it was
moments where he was spinning i liked
the record with him in rhapsody
but in totality the record the album
just felt like
he was just yelling and it felt like
just you know when you know
and you know when you're trying to enjoy
yourself with the club someone started
trying to pitch you
no
i really enjoyed the bust album i'm
probably i'm a lot higher on the bus
rhymes album than you are then i really
enjoyed it man
um oh okay i got russ at
okay and then i got a little baby at 10.
wow okay little baby is an
artist who i never ever thought would
make this list in in my entire life
based on like it being called the best
rappers
but man if he didn't have
a hell of a year uh and you know
he also probably gets most improved of
the year too most improved player
oh yeah absolutely like little bay if
this we if we did a hottest
mc's list he'd probably be number one
two and three hottest yeah
i think it's like him pop smoke and uh
and
probably righty rich and then and and
then you know you probably feeling the
baby and
and um who am i forgetting that would be
in that
i think megan would make that list megan
maybe uzi
yeah like that's a hot artist but uh
that's the hottest list which we used to
get pissed off about when mtv would do
he was on that panel yeah yeah and um i
remember voting for drake and they voted
for kanye but
that was that that was like four years
ago yeah so some of my honorable
mentions
are um boldy james
okay foley's nice yeah he had a crazy
year
um i also of course
uh west side gun i think we have to
just salute his body of work for the
year
pray for paris that's that's that's on
the list i'll give you a scene it's on
my list too
on the list yeah it's pretty high on my
list um
also i gotta i gotta show some love to
eminem i
actually thought eminem's album was uh
his best album in like 10 years
i really liked um recovery i liked
recovery a lot
yeah but recovery was 2 000 and was that
that was the one with like um
he was like walking down the road and
[ __ ] that was like 2010.
yeah that was a long time ago that was
2010 and since
recovery really it's been a whole lot of
[ __ ]
uh shout out to eminem shout out to paul
rosenberg no i love eminem
he's one of my favorite rappers ever and
i feel like with with this album
i finally was like yes this is the
eminem album
that i've i've just wanted him to make
all the features they didn't sound
forced it was a step in the right
direction the intro i remember
listening to that i thought that was
crazy you know so eminem that was
definitely i think
to your point it's probably his best
album in a while he toned down the like
forced ballads with uh skyler gray and
you know
pink and rihanna and you know whoever
the hell he was
like bro if i
when when when the track listening came
out and i saw her name on the track
i lost my [ __ ] mind i was like guys
will someone tell eminem to stop putting
this [ __ ] girl on records
i haven't listened to the b-side that
came out uh at nine o'clock last night
but nonetheless yeah i think you know
you gotta throw eminem in the honorable
mention now's in the honorable mention
jay elect in the honorable mention i
hope kind of watched him on that album
but you know
um you know shout out to jay electronica
but yeah i think i think
how about this for the year do you think
this was like i feel like this is
one of the best years in recent memory
as far as like
just the quality of music we got oh
absolutely i think there was a lot of
great moments a lot of great music that
came out and
a lot of it probably just didn't get the
exposure it deserved but
if you were a rap fan you know where to
find the good [ __ ] man like there was
great music all around the board for
sure
all right so look your your albums of
the year list
it should be out by now yeah i'm going
to put out maybe like in a few hours
well so yeah so this is going to come
out monday okay so
so so this will already have been out so
let's go over i'm going to run through
my list and you go through your list
i bet all right i got alfredo's number
one
um i got rtj4 is two
i got pray for paris at three
wow okay wow this is different i got
from a king to a god of four
okay burden of proof at five
um blast no love lost
but see is blast he's like though yeah
you know what
all right i'll tell you what
he's just one of my favorite albums of
the year so we're talking rap albums we
can
yeah we can move him over so what was
that that was six
so then i got detroit two at six okay
i got detroit two at six two you and i
both have the same sentiments about big
sean
love that album man love that [ __ ]
album
um i got my turn at seven
me too so i since i bumped something out
okay where are we at
[ __ ] is hard man i'm still wrestling
with my list if you want to be honest
i got um at eight
the allegory from royce okay i really
enjoyed that album
um at nine kings disease
wow
you're nazi nazi man why you haven't you
have a higher hell yeah they have it way
higher
hey man i i love the album nas is my
favorite rapper ever
right so like trust me like i love nas
you know what i'm saying i didn't listen
to jay-z for like 12 months of my
childhood because
yeah uh and then like well since we kind
of
bumped some [ __ ] out i think 10 i have
some honorable mentions that i have to
slide in but i
i kind of got my honorable mentions um
as uh savage mode two
meet the woo two and i really uh an
album i don't think a lot of people talk
about
that was really really solid i just have
as an honorable mention that i think p
people should at least
you know to tip their hat to his amines
album limbo was really good
someone else told me about amine's album
i mean he's almost [ __ ] fire man
yeah i had to do a deep dive on the
meaning yeah honestly like his album was
like i was driving back from san diego
and i just hit play on that [ __ ] and i
was like damn this [ __ ] is
solid like you no skips yeah
what do you got so for me again this is
still tentative it's written in pencil
okay
pencils shout out to pencils in 2020
so i got number one freddie gibbs
alfredo number two khan weighted machine
from king to a god
three stove god cooks oh
still got good serena reasonable drought
uh number four benny the butcher
burning of proof five nas king disease
six big sean detroit two seven little
baby my turn
uh eight pray for paris now nine to 10
is where it's getting kind of
hard for me certainly it's getting very
hard
and writing as of right now it says
larry june keep going number 10
jack harlow that's what they all say you
know what's crazy
is i i wrote this list last night
and i thought about this list last week
in cancun when his
i was in cancun bumping his album on the
beach yeah
and you're right about jack harlow i
gotta i think
because you know how i said my 10 spot
was kind of a floater like i think i
might have to slide jack harlow into
that 10 spot man
i'm not mad like i didn't know what to
think going into it but i'm listening to
it i'm like
i'm at like third track 13 i'm like wait
i didn't even skip anything like what
the [ __ ]
there's no skips it's a very easy listen
he's saying some fly [ __ ] he could rap
yeah play production like like dj drama
cannon like we're involved you know what
i'm saying it's not like
they let them out let him out to do what
he want like i felt like was really
annard and produced well
i'm not mad at that jack hollow album
like oh that jack harlow album is solid
it's really good yeah man i think i
think yeah
i think that that might be my i mean
that might be my 10. uh
but but like i got i've totally forgot
about that album because it obviously
just came out so when i put this list
yeah it just came out last week yeah i
heard it i was like yo what the [ __ ]
like this guy's
he's he's spitting so somebody else you
mentioned
that um is is from over here
and by over here i mean the west coast
uh is larry june and i feel like it's
dope to see
you know we always hear that uh you know
you guys over in new york are a little
biased
that's what i've heard yeah but larry
june
has has had a hell of a uh a career
you know building up his fan base and i
feel like it's dope to see
him get some real respect yeah i've got
hit to larry june this year and then
like a lot of
people that i respect as far outside of
music
they talk about like yo listen to this
larry june guy he's talking about
finances and like real life [ __ ] and
like
you know leveling up yeah good and
organic i was like yeah i'm gonna get
this guy's shot
right right right you know so i'm
listening to that i'm like yo this guy
is like picking up where jeezy left off
as far as thug motivation
really inspiring he's motivating he's
telling you how to get money and just
stop
chasing women and things that i think
that are really important for
you know consumers ears in 2020 so when
i heard his album
uh with harry fraud uh uh keep going
oh this [ __ ] is hard man definitely
shout out to larry jr man yes hey so let
me ask you this man
um uh you did your yo one more thing i
gotta ask how did little wayne get on
your list this year
you don't think lil wayne was spitting
i don't know i mean his timeless feature
was solid
you you had it you you were a lot
stronger on that than probably anyone
yo i heard i was like yo wade is going
[ __ ] super saiyan
i just can't think of the little wayne
song that i was like
i wouldn't say necessarily is defined by
a song per se
i just can't think of the project i was
like yo let me go listen to funeral or
let me go listen to [ __ ] no ceilings
three
i think he was spitting on funeral i
think he was spitting on no ceilings
three as well and also like
the feature on jack harlow uh
i think um what's up the joint that he
did the thomas feature
i feel like wayne could still rap at a
high level
now would i say the funeral was one of
the best albums of the year no
but i just think i thought you had him
kind of high man kind of high what about
number nine
wayne would have been number 10 if it
wasn't for stone guard club you should
have been like 15.
would have been really low everyone
thinks i hate little wayne already by
the way i'm a huge little white man
i'm not biased i love lil wayne everyone
thinks i hate him
because i because you know i i'm very
critical of lil wayne
because i'm like it you know i think
wayne is incredible
one of the greatest of all time right i
probably don't have him ranked as high
as most
but i just feel like after carter three
he's
after really the first no ceilings
because it was carter three then the
first no ceilings
he's just kind of left me a little empty
as a fan where i've just been like
wanting more
if that makes sense you know carter iv
was a little disappointing he had some
great singles
carter five was a lot you know it was
just a lot i still can't even think of
the carter five
like i've listened to it maybe twice
through and that's it
but i just i saw wayne on your list kind
of high and i was like
it was number nine you know i think that
was a fair i feel like it feels like the
old man still got it you know like he's
still rap
so that's why i had him at that place
yeah
i think if you're putting wayne on that
list you got to put m on that list
you think so i think m's album was very
listenable man
i think like if i did like a top 20
it'll be a little bit more room that's
fair
a lot more room to not offend people
exactly and you know
which rapper got the most offended by
your list it was either russ and stove
got cooks
they were offended they they oh are you
talking about
no no no no i know people hated the fact
you put russ on your list
i'm talking about like there was a lot
of people who were commenting on this
[ __ ]
right was there someone in particular
that kind of caught feelings that you
were like
i mean you know yeah he caught feelings
but he was bothered by
his exclusion or omission um which was
ransom
and i was surprised yo another honorable
mention
ransom had a good year but that's the
thing is like
and no disrespect to ransom but i just
didn't know and i know a lot of rap
man i know a lot of people no one
throughout this
year had said yo you need to check this
ransom project you know what i'm saying
it's like a lot of times you gotta
you gotta look at yourself like am i
doing enough to create awareness
right and i always say this too
sometimes it's harder to create the
interest than the actual music
so if there's no interest there who the
[ __ ] is gonna expect
and i'm sure ransom is spitting his ass
off but it's like dawg if i'm making the
best
rap list right and my criteria is based
on skill which i'm sure ransom has
of course gonna track and also presents
i think blacks a lot in that in that
department
that's fair um yeah i think uh it's
funny because i really wasn't hip to the
year he was having until i heard like
maul or somebody on the on the joe
budden podcast say like yo he might be
the mvp of the year i was like
let me go listen to what he's been doing
and he's definitely had a very
productive year but
yeah i definitely can see how people who
uh saw that list
the first person that they probably
would be like what the [ __ ] russ at four
that's the thing is like i'm like are
you listening to what this means they're
not
they're not they're not and it bugged me
out when i
went to the clubhouse room and people
were debating on the list
and they're acting like russ like he's a
[ __ ] alien i'm like dog you guys work
in the music business
like you guys act like you don't know
who the [ __ ] this guy is he's got more
plaques than your favorite rapper or
whoever you're managing
like this guy is super relevant like
he's been consistent
he's dropping music he's been dropping
music this whole year
dude it's crazy come on man you got to
put some respect in russell's name
and he was about to take benny on an
arena tour
come on man like it's it's crazy
um what's been your favorite moment of
the year hip-hop wise because there's
been a lot with verses and obviously
some certain projects but you know i'll
give you mine mine is i
really enjoyed the the gucci jeezy
verses i thought that that was
that was like crazy believe it was
happening
what about yours um my favorite rap
moment this year
versus definitely is up there um i think
uh what else happened this year [ __ ] you
put me on the spot kev now i'm drawing a
blank
uh [ __ ] before the world went to an end
the roc nation brunch i guess if that
counts
that was a i'm not invited to such
things so
it was for me because it's like you know
you've seen it's like the hip-hop prom
right
so i remember conway was there and he
was dressed up and rihanna was there i
was like yo
i'm gonna introduce you to rihanna he
said word so just like trying to
coordinate that together
yeah i mean um what's another good
hip-hop moment um i don't i'm drawing a
blink right now this is gonna question
that i'm gonna think about after i hang
up
and be like [ __ ] i forgot yeah for me
it's definitely the verses and then just
like on a personal level i got to see uh
you know i went to the griselda shows
here in l.a right before the pandemic
happened
and you know conway performing the cow
crying and [ __ ] while hover standing on
the side of the stage was crazy to
witness
right i mean i always love it when he
performs that song so
i miss shows man [ __ ] remember shows i
know
yo if you want to go to atlanta or south
carolina or
you know wherever down there all those
red states man they're still happening i
promise
did you see the nba young boy show that
happened like last week
yo what panda they got the cure down
there man
bro bro it's crazy i'm like that
happened yesterday
well this [ __ ] is over man i am not
missing out on nothing i'm going to
every listening
every concert in a basement i want in
i'm not hey i think i think when if
south by
ever comes back it's going to go up
again like it used to
[Music]
so man i feel like everybody wants to
experience
live events again so we're uh breaking
down this video
we're not breaking it down we're taking
a break in the video to tell you all
about our sponsors
odd socks all right listen man uh
oddssocksofficial.com
what the [ __ ] was that bro uh it was
like a [ __ ] pomeranian hair floating
in the air
anyway odd socksofficial.com keyword
bootleg kev
go over there get you some socks and
you'll save 20
off if you use that keyword they got
south park license
they got some ghostbusters pimp c mike
tyson
really the one that i really care about
is they got that wwe license you can get
these awesome nwo socks
and then they got their odd socks basics
you know for all the basic [ __ ] get
you some basic socks
even though they are very comfortable uh
they're probably the most comfortable
socks
actually not probably definitively the
most comfortable socks i've ever put on
my feet
yes all right and that goes for all
types of socks
so go to oddssoxoficial.com get some
socks by the way
spongebob socks the kind of fly right
christmas time's on the way
use the keyword bootleg kev 20 off
oddssocksofficial.com
support us by supporting odd socks let's
go so someone who
neither of us mentioned who
we just talked about ran like real quick
who i think a lot of uh
younger people would would take offense
to us not saying his name
for whatever reason um i don't got him
on my list you don't got him on but nba
young boy
yeah um i don't think he's like the best
like when i think of the best rapper i
don't think nba young boy comes to mind
i listen to his album um i think he
dropped like four projects this year
something some
some insane amount i listen to the last
one and um
and he's doing the numbers you don't i
don't care about the numbers you know
what i'm saying i mean i think that
tells a story i don't think it tells the
whole story uh
he he's super popular like you said on
youtube and
but i just don't i wasn't blown away by
anything that he said there wasn't
nothing that was like
guys let me press the rewind button i
didn't get that from yeah i enjoy some
of his [ __ ]
because obviously like i'm a club dj so
there's certain [ __ ] they're like i'm
like yo this [ __ ] goes up but like as
far as like
this year i haven't heard some nba young
boy [ __ ] that like was like
damn that [ __ ] was hard like it's just
maybe it's just not for me some
look some of this [ __ ] i've realized by
the way
i still haven't listened to uzi's album
so
i let my son tell me about it i'm just
like yo i already you know i
i just i've kind of just maybe that [ __ ]
that's that on my behalf like i probably
should tap in with i've heard a lot of
it you know that i've like
that that i've listened to but i haven't
like sat down
and pressed play and just let it ride
yeah i know i kind of know what you're
getting into when you listen to the uzi
album like it's
like the thing it was a correct well but
i don't think he showcases it that much
on his albums
on the the future project that he did he
had that song called about
like he really went in like okay give me
more of this uzi
but um he's more like vibes and things
like that but i wouldn't
put uzi on my best rapper list i
couldn't do that
real quick um it's crazy because
the the most memorable verses that i can
think of this year when i say verses i
don't mean the battle but like
people's verses um
they they're they're free like to me
that the one that now mind you i really
have to sit down and think about this
but i think of conway
fire in the booth that's you know what
you asked me about moment that's what i
wanted to say
conway's freestyle on charlie slaw
wow bruh i watch that once a week
i do too you know also i also watched
your joint with freddie gibbs when you
did last year
oh yeah you know what you know funny
story about that is fred came to the
studio and was like uh
like we were doing an interview and then
i was like oh you know you gotta rap
right and he literally wrote that [ __ ]
in like five minutes and then nailed it
yeah like he was like yo
uh pick a beat so we picked the drake
money in the grave and then
he was like just let me chill in here
for five minutes and just come up with
something
and then he was like come back in and
then he laid it down
oh [ __ ] yeah wow he didn't come to the
station that day with the
expectations to rap and then he laid
down some crazy [ __ ] that's amazing
fred's a [ __ ] mutant
like that's i thought that was like
prepared no
nah bro yeah no fred's a [ __ ] alien
bro
and then obviously you know he did la
leakers freestyle last year which was
[ __ ] crazy yes baby
yeah once a week bro be an actual
remix with him and uh dom kennedy
another verse that like
it also is la leakers verse this year um
and that's the simba freestyle man yo
get out of my head kev
yo i was just about to say kev simba
is going to be a problem like if i had
to do an honorable mention
best rap he's on that list he's
whoo simba is amazing
that freestyle yo was [ __ ]
crazy simba is nice so many and just the
confidence and the
and just the delivery of those lines and
that freestyle we're so
s like uh and mind you out he's a really
good friend of mine like
really good close like he was on our
show like three years ago like to give
you some insight like
i've been known simba for a while and
man
his project is you know it's crazy
because his project didn't come out the
way it was supposed to come out
so like two weeks ago they were playing
me some like they a lot of the songs
were on there right but like
there's there's a song called west side
griselda that was supposed to be on the
album
with him and jason cash that because the
samples didn't work out but
but yes simba's crazy he's he's
incredible like i'm interested to see
what he's going to do in 2021
like he's the kind of rap i like rappers
like that it's like when you when i
listen to them it makes me want to quit
rapping
and i can't even rap right like what am
i doing this for
it's like [ __ ] let me start from scratch
like he's
he's a rapper's rap he's dope man like i
want to get more
in tune to what he's got going on in
2021 yeah i think he's gonna have a
crazy year
um and then and then i think the
congrats russ freestyle was probably
uh up there as well i think and it's
crazy because those are the three that
just come to my head and
and i'm not saying that there are better
verses but it's like all three of those
verses are all from freestyles
technically
absolutely the congratulation from russ
is really dope um i listen to that
probably like once a week as well
um love the absolute verse on you didn't
put absolute verse on your on your
features i wanted to pick one from each
other that's fair i'm gonna put multiple
but it could have
easily absorbed with the crooked eye
because he set the tone
and yes crooked eye just went ape [ __ ]
on that
that uh on stockholm syndrome um but
i like freddie gibbs man freddy gibbs on
100 ounce 500 ounces
on west side guns album was that was the
one where he had the line about uh
about uh take a load off this low
management right yeah
yeah yeah that [ __ ] was crazy like marcy
and uh west side
i love that b alchemist is a [ __ ]
fool
uh he killed that joint i love
conway conway whatever kind conway and
freddie are like ken and ryu like
i'm on the edge of my seat anytime he's
right yeah conway is
is my um he's my favorite um
like when it comes to just like his his
versatility to be able to like just kill
you with some crazy bars
or just give you like the most relatable
verse about some crazy traumatic [ __ ]
he's like man i know he's not like
the you know the most like yo benny's
the guy right now right
but i think conway is like like he's
like the people's champ
if that makes sense he's right there and
man he played me a record con
i'm telling you now on your show kev
he's sitting on
a hit he played me um
his entire shady album so i might have
heard it
um maybe how long would he play for you
a couple weeks ago okay okay he might be
something new yeah because he was up
here
in probably october september and he
played me like
this was before his album dropped so it
was like a couple weeks prior
but then he played me his whole [ __ ]
the whole shady records debut
yeah that's the same one i heard he has
a record i said it on live so it's not a
secret
like that he has a record produced by
hitmaker and um
produ produced by hitmaker
oh you know he played me some other [ __ ]
that was um i want to say
jeremiah was on the hook or something
and he was like i heard that
he was like i don't think i don't think
we can get this one cleared though yeah
yeah i heard that's a monster but this
is what i'm talking about
i've heard that i didn't hear the stefan
dawn record but yo it's crazy because we
did talk about a lot of the records like
you know
because we did like an hour-long
interview and i was just talking about
both albums he had just played me
neither was out so
yeah he's got some big features and you
know i'm excited for him man shout out
to conway i think result is going to
have even i mean benny's got two records
with drake tucked
like i heard those but you know what it
is about this year too
i love what benny the hoga zelda
movement russ
and freddie have been doing this year
it's like they're
stockpiling this ammunition a lot of
rappers took a break this year man but
these guys have been consistently
working
and i feel like 2021 once we get through
this pandemic it's gonna be a
big breakout year for those guys because
of the music that they have been putting
out
do you think also like the inv this is
what i told
um fred and benny i was like you know
what's dope about
2020 obviously it sucks you can't hit
the road but you know people are
listening to music differently they're
listening to it in their headphones
they're listening to it in their car
because they're driving uber all day
they're not standing on couches
you know what i mean and so i feel like
this year
was a special moment to like really like
say something in your music absolutely
absolutely i feel like you know people
feel like
rap music only exists in the nightclub
or in a lounge
places well i like to i'm not listening
to the turn up drink when i'm cleaning
my house or i'm in my car i just want to
listen to some really good
rap music with meaningful lyrics so just
something entertaining
and those guys have been doing that
throughout this whole year
so you know like you said people are
listening a little bit differently i'm
not mad at that like let's let's let's
get back to the lyrics you know
and um we can still have fun we can
still sing throw baby
but shout out to throat baby
yeah let me ask you this um what do you
what what do you guys have um
like like 20 what's your 2021 looking
like right now
man i don't [ __ ] know i mean i
thought 2020 was going to be the year
you know so of course we all did no
remember how we thought 2019 was such a
shitty year and everybody was posting
the memes about man 2019 get it the [ __ ]
up out of here
2019 was fantastic dude i was like yo
it's gonna get great it's gonna be
better for 2020
and then march you know the world went
to [ __ ] so
you know like i said you playing in god
laughs but hopefully
you know 2021 we get the rap radar
podcast out of our hiatus stage and we
will be back with some new interviews
and new conversations and um
just new opportunities you know talking
to artists and
you know traveling across the country
and getting these
um getting these interviews popping
when you guys cause i do think um the
rap radar podcast
as far as just raw interviews right
i feel like you guys do the best
interviews
i like i really mean that thank you man
and that's with me having to get through
elliot's laugh whenever it happens you
know
shout out to elliot the goat but but i
do think like you guys
like legit if we're like just pound for
pound who's doing like the best
interviews i feel like it's you guys
especially from like for like a fan like
i feel like you guys will ask
questions because you're fans and you'll
ask those like kind of little like super
niche off the road questions that only
like maybe like a
like the core hardcore guys will like
tap that's what really what i
appreciated about that drake interview
is you guys kind of
touched on a lot of [ __ ] that like
nobody else would have talked about in a
drake interview
yeah man like i think that's the thing
too like you can attest to this you know
at the end of the day you got to be a
fan
of them you know i think that enthusiasm
comes up
comes across you know in our
conversation so
you know i i just i love it man and i
appreciate i appreciate the the kind
words
because you know we dedicate a lot of
man hours into preparing for these
interviews and things like that
right right yeah and he's like you said
i mean there's and then there's always
the people you interview that you're not
fans of which they're always just
it's just they're just going to be
different conversations absolutely and
you know sometimes you become a fan
of the person that you hurt a fan of
prior to so you know
just humanizing an artist and you know
getting to know them a little bit better
so
that's fair man uh anything uh obviously
rap radar still ticking the blog era is
you know let me ask you this because you
guys have one of the biggest blogs ever
by the way
shout out to you and and uh amaya and
everybody at rap radar who always would
support anything i was doing
um but you guys were one of the
gatekeepers right yeah
for like eight or nine years yeah you
guys could change someone's
career we had a hand in a few jobs
hey by the way it's crazy because i just
i just tapped in with uh 360 again
recently
you were
like we always hear that the blog era is
dead right
um i mean i i don't necessarily disagree
but like obviously rap radar still a
website you guys still post [ __ ] like
it's still around shout out to uh paul
aka the big homie he kind of keeps us
afloat and you know
as far as that goes it's still i think
that's the beauty of what the website
still provides is like a lot of these
domains have
expired or they've no longer exist and
the archives are gone but you know our
website's still up the archives are
still there so you could kind of go back
and
you know check a post from 2009 or 2018.
it's still there and um i feel like
that's good you know it's not what it
once was
but we still have a presence and i think
that's important and you guys pivoted
unlike a lot of other people in that
space yeah you know
um i i realized where the game was kind
of going
more towards conversations and things
and you know shout out to uh
uh combat jack rest in peace combat
uh juan epstein they were doing it nice
tell this i think we could i think we
could do this too
so you know we just wanted to keep the
brain we could have named it anything i
was like let's just keep it for brand
recognition to wrap rate our podcast and
then
five years later here we are what about
you um
what are what are some um podcasts that
you actually like listen to on it
on a regular basis um i listen to little
i try to listen a little bit everybody
listen to yes yours as well
sheamus plug um i listen to lip service
joe budden whenever i can that's just
like a [ __ ] movie yeah the joe budden
[ __ ] it's like okay
am i going on a road trip joe's great
for a good road trip
you know um i listen to uh i listen to
alec baldwin
uh he has his podcast called here's the
thing okay
listen to whatever i can you know i
watch a lot of clips
the clips are our clutch for me yeah
especially for the joe budd and [ __ ]
because i was like oh cool i could just
hear them talk about this album that
came out and see what they think
to sit through four hours you know
listen to charlemagne
and of course it's so you know my taste
varies
yeah 100 man uh well look i appreciate
you for
for for checking in um and and and yeah
i was like yo
i gotta i gotta we gotta do a year in
podcast there's like there's only really
one person i want to talk to
about this year before i let you go
though i'm curious
knowing uh the the narrative about the
the the
the east coast bias what does that mean
i don't know but this is what i'm asking
you right can we
can you kind of give me uh you know
maybe four or five
artists now we already talked about
larry june so that's one
right from this side from the west coast
from the state of california could be la
the bay wherever
who are are really on your radar so to
speak yeah i mean
l.a i mean that what i say la the west
coast got some really
good talent i mean outside of the tde
camp you know that's
off bat of course of course but i do
like you know reason he could spit his
ass off
of course larry june definitely a tap
with mozzie
um who else am i uh [ __ ] with
i feel like i'm missing some folks i
know i am but i'm going to kick myself
afterwards hey d smokes project was
solid too man i mean he got money for a
grammy
he's smoking he gets busy as well um
but those those are the ones right now
that stick out my mind a lot simba we
talked about symbol he's from the bank
i think he's holding it down man like he
has potential to really be something you
know going to 2021 so i'm looking
i'm trying to think oh okay i got to put
you on some la guys please
uh there's a there's a dude named nana
from out here nana
he's fire n-a-n-a yes
if you just go on youtube type in he's
got a song with reason
he's crazy there's another dude named
katori walker
that's super dope he put a project out
called idols this year
um write this down and then uh
i think this coming year you'll really
um
definitely you know jason cash will be a
factor out of la
he's uh that he's he's signed with
dallas
and and and he's you know him and simba
are real close
so but yeah katori walker nana um
those would be the two the two or three
jason cash but but check out the nana
project that [ __ ] is special
i'm definitely going to be tapped in
thank you kevin oh good thank you for
your time bro and
and i i look forward to seeing you break
the internet again with this album's
list
trust me i think they're gonna hate
they're gonna fry me to the stake man
no i think we had a solid list and i'm
glad you're hot as high on big sean as i
was too
big sean is actually short actually hit
me about the list too he was like number
five
every time i read big sean's messages i
hear his voice
so he's like number five what about this
verse and i'm like sure
you're nice detroit too is crazy
i think it's his best project too i
think it's i i think i think i actually
think it's
better than the first detroit and i
always kind of had that as his it was
like that or dark sky paradise
yeah you know i think sean's nice man
like
he's got to put some respect on big sean
yeah listen i always say when we when we
talk about the
you know there's the mount rushmore and
it's always drake cole kendrick and then
i guess you probably would put travis up
there for the last
three or four years that's a
conversation man
right and if we're and and that's
excluding the like kanye and hoaves
right right sean is like the the leader
of that next tier right
here's a kid's a hot take i feel like if
big sh i'm doing a picture if
travis scott had uh if he was a
lyrically
more inclined rapper drake kendrick
kohl's
he would be at that table but as far as
his notoriety and celebrity and artistry
he's
i would definitely say he's there as
well i feel like
he's the only person that i thought had
more
you know pete kanye was like the coolest
dude in the world like
everyone dressed like kanye i feel like
travis scott
for lack of better terms first of all he
makes great music yeah absolutely
you said like like like lyrically
there's better rappers for sure right
that's right but he makes amazing music
um
and i'm not sure anyone's ever had the
kids in his back pocket like he has ever
in hip hop
travis is he's a [ __ ] cash cow he's
different
right now like he's got the era of the
18 to 25 year old
that's a fact so hey the last thing
we're gonna leave with i had i had an
argument
uh yeah uh maybe two days ago with
somebody
i just need you to uh let me know if you
agree or disagree i said to somebody
that nobody in the history of hip-hop
was ever bigger at their peak
i'm not talking about over their span of
their career or 10-year run
i'm talking about peak okay then 50 cent
is snoop dogg i think i agree with that
because before you even said that i was
thinking of the artist in my head i was
like you better say 50 cent yeah 50. 50
doggy style error snoop that like
whatever year and a half
when he had this murder charge and then
50 cent
we haven't anything like that as far as
peak
yeah i would agree with that i think
that's a fact well
it's beautiful hey man me and you are
like [ __ ] well you know
our lists are definitely you know
there's a few disconnects but i think
we're pretty
we're pretty [ __ ] spot on with a lot
of opinions here that's true i think if
you're a rad fan it was 50 cent
peak like 2003 oh my gosh
like oh my god like
what the [ __ ] he was standouts at that
time man
yo it's crazy people might be too young
for snoop
dogg but when snoop doggy style 1993
like come on man you just had to be
there you had to be there
and i was there but i was like seven i
remember it yeah
yo beat out thank you for checking in
man i appreciate your time and uh and
look forward to what you guys got coming
for the new year man
yes sir thank you man appreciate it